foreign
[Music]
what are you guys doing in Mexico
I'm looking for a dentist appointment
okay there you go thank you since Corona
hit I've seen actually a lot more body
carriers bringing drugs across
go come on
because we're not letting so much
traffic come in
she said her baby dad lives over there
yeah
right that doesn't make any sense
two females were referred to me in
secondary uh they were referred because
their story not adding up
where do you live I live in Ohio you
live in Ohio yeah but I'm from India so
what are you doing down here
so you drove all the way down here from
Ohio yeah
what would drive was that whole day
and what are you guys bringing from
Mexico to the United States
ourselves nothing else no
so there's nothing in your bags there's
no drugs on your person or inside of
your person
neither one of you
okay cool
lately there has been a higher rise with
people between 20 and 35 smuggling
narcotics
when you guys started going through her
bag and everything they both started
whispering freaking out to each other
and she kept reaching her hand under so
she's probably in the smaller bag
covered has sparked a lot of nutrients
people who would never do it are doing
it now simply because there's less jobs
so they need the money
we have been getting a lot of internal
or hidden on their body
so how long have you guys in Mexico for
two hours I don't think I hope
you said you were visiting your my
daughter's daddy
um
[Music]
can I just see him for myself
her baby father lives in Mexico now
because he got deported she only has one
other Crossing normally most people if
their family gets deported they go see
them every weekend or more often than
four months ago
just doesn't make any sense doesn't add
up
where do you live I live in Tucson you
live in Tucson now
when I was asking them questions they
kept Whispering back and forth to each
other switching around in their seats
negative
but they didn't find anything on their
bags at that point is requested for a
pat down just to make sure they didn't
have anything else on their person
[Music]
[Music]
there's a bunch of packages in here from
Netherlands
so we're looking for narcotics
anyway in Europe are pretty good
packages to check
so yeah we have Great Britain
this is a package from the UK
and
position
until you got a package coming from
Netherlands says it has documents in it
[Music]
case but inside there's no CD
doesn't look right
so we're gonna take a look at that one
I don't see any documents in here
are you buying a video game it's not
just gonna be blank like this and this
is Puffy there's red flags all over this
something interesting
there's a
Rocky substance
we see a lot of MDMA from the
Netherlands
the person has
put cards inside thanking them for being
a good customer
they're not going to get this order
[Music]
and we're gonna test what we thought
because MDMA
[Music]
watch
[Music]
positive for MDMA ecstasy
but this is a schedule one so it's going
to be seas and it'll be destroyed
foreign
every time you cross the border you are
subject to inspection some people get
more inspection than other people
sometimes that inspection is just as
simple as a primary inspection of hey
what were you doing Mexico other times
when their story isn't adding up or
something like that then they're subject
to additional inspection sometimes that
goes as far as a canine search or pat
down search and you know that's all
within our authorities of working at the
borders
[Music]
no
all right actually
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all depends on what's going on the
inspection that the officer is doing
it
[Music]
no we're good I mean we did what we can
so I'm good
we just have to do our due diligence and
once we have it done then we have to let
them go you know there's only so much
that we can do here all right take care
of these take your bags have a good day
thanks yeah see you never First Time in
Mexico yeah
we do have a lot of unhappy customers
but at the end of the day everybody
understands it's what our job is this is
how we Safeguard America
foreign
[Music]
thanks for everybody coming out today I
greatly appreciate it we were recently
contacted by JFK Airport they found a
parcel label to individuals here in the
Denver area that contained 123 grams of
ecstasy tablets that had the logo Chupa
chubas on them
about 2014 2015 they hit the dark Market
they're real popular with the party
scene Rave scene specifically in the UK
instead of MDMA
key ingredient was PMA
which acts like MDMA
but it's stronger and it takes longer to
hit
so that results in a bunch of Overdose
deaths in the UK
that of course came quickly on our radar
here because this amount of tablets
coming into Denver could potentially
have some uh some horrible effects so
today we are doing a search warrant
operation the tablets they're addressed
to a mid-20s female usually PMA it's
related to dark net and cryptocurrency
so we're gonna be looking for drug
packaging paraphernalia shipping Parcels
devices phones anything like that
just got to be safe today guys
we hope to counter this person her
residents were the package was addressed
hopefully we get their cooperation and
be able to work this case back from
Denver to the overseas vendor that's
potentially Distributing you know these
types of tablets all over the world this
is one of those cases where we're trying
to stop something before it happens
do we have any intel from surveillance
at the residence if there's any movement
I haven't heard anything from dpd all
right 10-4
we're not sure what it's going to look
like once we get inside so safety is the
top priority today
[Music]
the third position of the back alley
all right copy that we're just pulling
in the side parking lot
s of back door
open the door
I got someone on that side
female he's coming
let's go
[Music]
watch the back door
open the door
got someone on that side
female she's coming
not our Target brown hair
so the team just entered the residence
with the search warrants what we found
was a roommate's girlfriend that was
home our primary target wasn't home
you mind if I just hang out with you
right here okay
we did find and identify the room that
she stays in inside the apartment
[Music]
we'll start our search and then see if
we can find anything
[Music]
search found some residue some small
baggies of like white powdery substance
you know possibly cocaine
as well as a number of electronic items
Target wasn't at the house
we got some information that you might
be at the boyfriend's house
[Applause]
okay all right so let's all go over to
the next residence
well we're gonna check this level again
right
we're the second largest seaport in the
country biggest Seaport on the East
Coast
foreign
this port has vessels coming from all
countries ships carrying containers with
anything from chemicals to scrap metal
uh you name it it comes into this port
[Music]
the open containers we're looking for an
narcotics we're trying to make sure
everything's legitimate
you have this Backscatter x-ray which
when you walk along you'll get a picture
so you can see if something's out of the
ordinary
our mission is to keep bad guys and bad
things out of the country
now you guys want to start up
there's probably about three or four
thousand containers discharging off this
vessel today we're doing pop and Taps
meaning random inspections we have
limited time before these containers are
loaded up on a train attracted trailer
for distribution to the United States
the more we check everything out the
better the chances of us finding some
narcotics today
right here
when we open the container we verify
that the commodity matches the Manifest
and check for any Contraband of any
source
more booze
so this is good you guys
sugar
[Music]
this is a probe of what it has just has
divots inside of it if we happen to
break into a kilo of cocaine there might
be some white powder in the uh actual
divot
that should be all right
the shipment here is good to go
honey
we had a load in barrels of honey just
like this
here's one barrel we may have to open
it sounds a little Hollow
it could just be less honey in one of
the barrels it could be narcotics uh
that's probably the only options
[Music]
on top of this
oh
[Music]
[Music]
there you go don't eat that honey
Crow came negative
the reason why it sounded a little
different was because there was less
honey in the container
um as you can see it's very sticky
keep moving
[Music]
we're doing in Mexico oh my grandparents
they're trying anything
hello
what were we doing in Mexico
you're visiting friends you say that
like you don't know
you don't know what you're doing in
Mexico
no
Mexico
huh
in Mexico
[Music]
so when I was asking her very simple
questions that we
usually ask she was avoiding those
and that is very strange
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I checked her bags and there was nothing
inside of her bags however it's like 100
and some degrees she's wearing a jacket
she's wearing leggings so there's
possibly something on her
foreign
countered they usually are not involved
with the cartel initially
but they are in like a struggling spot
s
[Music]
oh
you'll follow us we're gonna go that way
because we're gonna search you like we
said
another red flag is when people object
to a pack on what she did we do need to
have supervisor approval
so once we get approval they can't
necessarily deny that pat down
so from there we would take that step
further
Copo is a supervisor in there
[Music]
is another
so not right now
you don't have any jacket we need to
search
okay yeah
are you understanding me this border
there's a lot of smuggling that goes on
through here you know we can't tell just
by you telling us right we have to do
the search
and everybody is subject to search
all right okay
usually everyone's pretty compliant just
because it they don't have anything they
don't have anything all right
now we're gonna go over here
yes there's possibly something on her
that's why she's acting so suspicious so
nervous so that's where I took that the
step further
foreign
[Music]
so she didn't have anything I really
thought she did
cool
she had the behaviors of somebody that
actually had something like the whole I
don't have anything I don't have
anything in there
um why are you doing this and then she
started crying she made it very
difficult to where it's like it made it
seem like she had something so like she
just followed our whole like what we're
looking for
was that an adventure or not
our Behavior her behavior was horrible
today we were out on a Target that was
attempting to receive ecstasy if these
tablets are tied to overdose deaths you
know in the UK we certainly don't want
that uh that chemical those tablets here
in our community
our Target hadn't been at the house for
maybe two three days uh she does have a
boyfriend that lives about a mile from
there so we're going down to the
boyfriend's house
to knock and see if our Target may be
there and we'll see what happens
so we can go
see if anyone answers the door
[Music]
foreign
our primary target wasn't here
although we did a brief interview with a
boyfriend of the target he says that
pizza has no knowledge of her into that
buying any extra seed although he
recalls about a month ago someone asking
her to use the address
in a lot of these cases what we see is
people using
other individuals addresses to distance
themselves from the criminal activity
so we're headed to review that
electronic evidence from you know the
search warrants to determine who is the
end person in this chain that actually
ordered this package
foreign
looks like bags of chia seeds just
seeing if there's any impossible breaks
hidden inside of them
currently there's nothing in them
[Music]
we'll take a look inside so we have a
container here about 1300 kilos I
believe of tea manifested in there
all right
up up heads up
all right
no it looks just like bags looks like
rolls of burlaps
yeah you can smell like
all right it doesn't smell good
good
you really can't get into that whole
container it's too much stuff in there
anything it'll be in the back I guess so
we'll seal it up we'll get it out to the
warehouse
oh Mike
see we didn't see any tea so at all so
it's in the back somewhere
so we'll get it to the warehouse we'll
check it out we'll have everything taken
out and that's what we'll get a better
look at it all right we'll see
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I got no blade in here
[Applause]
foreign
but it doesn't smell very good
check it out it does look like a tea
but it doesn't smell very good okay
it does smell like cat
leaves contain amphetamines and are
legal in the United States in most
European countries
however in the Middle East in the Horn
of Africa there are no restrictions on
its use or distribution and in Israel
cot has become a party drug
they usually go to areas that have large
Muslim populations the Muslim people use
this not only for its hallucinogenic
properties but also as an appetite
suppressant
there are certain times of the year when
they have to fast
should be good with this one
this is a Consolidated shipment which
means you have two shipments in one
container
we have all the pallets are labeled
which one belongs to which
first one how many Pilots let's make
sure it matches up with the paperwork
it has the same shipper one is going to
Boulder Colorado uh the other shipment
is going somewhere in New Jersey
so they're going to take samples from
different parts of the container and
you're going to take all those samples
to the CVP laboratory and let the
chemists the scientists let us know if
it does have the alkaloids to prove that
it is narcotic
foreign
[Music]
how's everything going good good you get
anywhere with any of the uh the
electronics yeah I finished the
extraction on her iPhone
what'd you find here's the report let me
show you
so we had a search warrant on our
initial targets phone we imaged it we're
able to pull a logical extraction which
is the files the chats yeah there's a
lot of good stuff between her and her
boyfriend about you know
his roommate being involved
we have iMessages and texts between her
and her boyfriend's roommate so really
we're talking about another individual
yeah here's the first conversation with
her boyfriend's roommate
and she's asking for
some stuff some Molly
she's asking do you have Molly yeah I
mean he says I have lots of it but then
it gets pretty quickly into you
him asking her
about a package
talking about the package coming he
sends the tracking number receipt
he's ordering it he's tracking it and
then he's telling him he's telling her
when it's coming
it's looking then like the roommate oh
yeah of the boyfriend
had something to do with oh yeah
definitely
we have a new Target which is the
roommate of the boyfriend based on the
chats it's clear that he was
communicating with the first female
Target to receive the parcels they never
really talk about it again I think
that's because the of the interception
because we have it
all right so clearly there's a pattern
of her receiving packages for him yeah
she seems to be unwitting as to the
contents
she's just a drop for him
what we're kind of seeing here today is
an individual taking advantage of
someone else for the receipt of you know
Controlled Substances so they can get in
trouble but we need to talk to uh
this fella oh yeah with an eye looking
towards a potential search warrant I'm
going around
you guys ready yeah let's do it how do
you know each other
you know what are you guys doing in
Mexico
take care
can you put your Backpacker here what
are you bringing back with you
how long were you there in Mexico
I think the fact that a lot of people
are unemployed depressed on the pandemic
is increasing the demand for Narcotics
boy you gotta go boys
so we are definitely on high alert here
in The Pedestrian area
I'm gonna search you with my dog we're
gonna run a lot more operations with
canines trying to find those drug loads
coming on people or in people I don't
see any follow me this way
the trends are for sure picking up
we had a body carrier come through our
pedestrian Port earlier internally
carrying what we suspect to be narcotics
we're going to be testing it to see what
it is this subject here was referred by
the primary officer she basically said
that she had a short trip all the way
from Washington down to Nogales for one
day which for us that isn't that doesn't
make sense
two nice station we found that she was a
internal care for some type of pills
we're going to be testing it here today
[Music]
[Music]
he's testing positive
[Music]
so let's put this on the scale and see
how much we have
231.2 grams
that's pretty good seizure for Pure
Fentanyl
each of those pills are very very
dangerous
anytime we find a low like this it's a
great day
but it reminds us to stay vigilant
to use any means necessary to get their
drugs to the borders do not move
anybody could be smuggling narcotics so
we have to keep looking
Finance learned
Pat her down
[Music]
he's on our left side do not move okay
okay
we're gonna find everything
no get my dog alert to you so
just stand by we're gonna do a pet
downtown
the breed the Belgian Malinois is just
phenomenal their nose is so much more
stronger than what we pick up on
the all they know is work work
so this one right here
later
before they walk that way
you smoke marijuana okay until you do
she said she smokes so that might be it
sometimes if they like smoke weed or
something like that there's still
residual odor and it gets stuck to their
clothes
thanks everyone for coming out today uh
this is a continuation of the search
warrant she was receiving pills which
was involved with some overdose deaths
over in the United Kingdom which made
this a you know a huge public safety
issue for us here in Denver to try to
figure out you know where these are
coming from found a lot of great digital
evidence that led us to the house that
we're going to today
so we have a warrant today the target
he's the roommate of the boyfriend of
our previous Target we're gonna see if
he'll talk to us but we're definitely
there looking for electronics or
anything like that so everyone be safe
you guys know what to do
Ryder Aaron radio check
fine clear
we're gonna start creeping
what's particularly important about this
case again is the potential for you know
these pills to cause overdose deaths
here in our community so we're out in
more in our Public Safety and
investigatory role to try and stop you
know the flow of these counterfeit type
tablets getting into the community
we'll go to the door knocking announce
you know police with a search warrant uh
we'll wait to give a chance for the
residents to come down and open the door
and then if that does not happen uh we
will access the the residents uh the
best way we can
is this wall in the front all right so
let's make sure we separate the two of
them
today we're going to be processing two
seizures of cot we had to send it to the
lab for the laboratory to tell us that
it does have the hallucinogenic
properties and the lab analyzed this and
told us it is dried Cod
this is a significant amount of cot
that's come into the country
yeah it is
right now they're unloading the
container
palette by pallet taking it over to our
pallet jack that also gives us a weight
so kilo is 429.5
6 pounds
all right so that's that one
hey pop can you separate these so is
this the second seizure this is gonna be
the second one okay
it was a Consolidated load which came
out to a total of almost 7 000 kilos
it's just something that started
recently that was our third significant
seizure and again that's all in the last
few months it usually comes in smaller
amounts Express Consignment through the
airport fifteen thousand pounds so
pretty significant as far as I'm
concerned
that's what they said
it's on the next one
next stop
in secondary right now we have a
gentleman who came down here at 4am to
look for a dentist right in the middle
have a seat okay the dentist here open
later but they're not open that late so
the story just didn't make sense to the
primary officer do you have anything on
your person
no that was in search Okay arms straight
up
all right what is it
do not move
canines learned
all right canine's learning
Fentanyl
he went into secondary they asked him if
he had anything on him he said no the
dog alerted uh to his groin area and he
immediately said yes that he has some
fentanyl pills down there
he had about 176 grams of fentanyl pills
inside of him that were double wrapped
with condoms
that's a lot of pills to be inside
somebody
so we seized the drugs and he'll be sent
to the local authorities where they will
continue on with the prosecution you
want to escort him with me you know
escort him we're gonna take him the head
outside hey go ahead
Markham be careful don't overstep yeah
take little tiny babies
got the rock star Dave
good boy you had a good boys yes good
boy I think the dog is probably one of
the best tools to have honestly
good boy
they always always seem to just Amaze
you you know
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
open it
after we made entry into the residence
we found a target of the investigation
the agents are talking to the individual
who we believe is the actual recipient
of this package or who ordered the
package online and one more thing for
the search warrant is written in there
for biometrics
so we got to see your finger a portion
of the warrant talks about Biometrics
and using you know face or fingerprint
to open up a phone we're just completing
that step right now I'm not asking for
your permission it's like in the court
you are required to do that
foreign
confident almost cocky in some sense he
does kind of know obviously why we are
here
[Music]
I was willing if you saw more with me
yeah
people looking for stress relief and
everything
we found a numerous electronic items in
the house that we're going to be taken
back to our forensic lab to be analyzed
our next steps are to conduct forensic
analysis see if we can't determine where
this packages came from the source of
the drugs the overseas vendor on the
dark web this is uh definitely the key
to it
[Music]
[Music]
what's important about this particular
case is to try and stop you know the
flow of these tablets and potentially
you know causing injury and or death to
people in the community that may find
themselves taking them okay great today
we did exactly that and I consider what
we've accomplished a true success
[Music]